you
[Music]
nice to meet you all I'm Robert I do
research in machine learning and
distributed systems and I'm gonna tell
you about ray which is an open-source
project we've been building at Berkeley
with a number along with a number of
collaborators outside of Berkeley as
well so ray is an open source project
it's being used by a bunch of different
companies of different sizes and it you
know both in research and in production
and for many different use cases so I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about why
we're building this project and what
what sort of the intended use case is so
at its core what we're building is a
distributed system a general-purpose
distributed system that's capable of
supporting all of the different
computational patterns and applications
that arise in the machine learning
ecosystem so everything from data
collection and data processing to model
training prediction serving hyper
parameter search and so on and I'll say
more about this in a little bit so in
addition to the core system we're also
building fleshing out the ecosystem and
a collection of libraries on top of Ray
which implement and support these
workloads so why are we doing this well
here's a depiction of the distributed
computing landscape today from a very
machine learning centric perspective so
you have special-purpose systems for a
number of different important workloads
if you want to do distributed training
you have tools systems like [ __ ] Avadh
or distributed tensorflow for doing that
if you want to do stream processing you
have systems like flink or other systems
for doing that if you want to do models
serving it's taking a trained model and
sending predictions or recommendations
back to some application we have model
serving tools for that so these systems
are all very powerful but this poses a
serious challenge for cross-cutting
applications that need to integrate many
of these different computational
patterns together so as soon as you have
some reinforcement learning application
or some online learning application that
needs to do not just stream processing
but also model training and also
prediction serving then you're you're
either going to you're doing work that
crosses boundaries of these different
systems so either you're going to do one
of two things
you're either going to try to stitch
multiple different systems together and
build an application by gluing these
different systems together or you're
gonna build a new system from scratch to
support your application and both of
these are approaches are things that
people do in practice so if you're
stitching multiple different systems
together one challenge you face is
efficiently moving data across system
boundaries with without the performance
overhead another challenge you'll face
is learning how to use all these
different systems and training people
and in how to use them you'll have to
reconcile different fault tolerance
models and things like that if you end
up building a new system from scratch
and this is the approach that is often
taken in reinforcement learning so open
AI deep mind places like that in order
to implement their reinforcement
learning applications build new
distributed systems from scratch to
support these applications and that can
work well but it can also impose a
really high engineering burden on
application development so what we are
trying to do with Rae is to take this
collection of special-purpose
distributed systems and move to a model
where we have a single general-purpose
system where all of these different
computational patterns can be
implemented as libraries or applications
on top and that's that level of
generality is important for being able
to support applications that cross that
implement that require many of these
different computational patterns so I'll
give you an example and financial builds
an app called Ali pay which is used to
pay for many things throughout China the
app looks something like this on the on
the Left and there's a banner ad so the
app ant financial offers many different
financial services to their users and
hundreds of different services and so in
order to recommend different services
that a user may be interested in they
build a recommendation model which fills
out this banner ad that's highlighted in
red now the way this works these
recommendations need to be personalized
based on a user's activity so as the
user is navigating through the app that
data is streamed off to the backend
processed by a stream processing system
then fed into used
incremental e-train new recommendation
models and then recommendations from
those models are served back to the app
to actually fail to actually recommend
something in the in the ad and before
before using Ray this system was built
by stitching together a stream
processing system a model training
system and a model serving system and
there was due to the complexity of the
architecture they weren't able to update
the recommendations more than once a day
now now this system is implemented on
top of race so the streaming the
training and the serving are all done on
a built on top of Ray and they're
updating the model every five they're
updating the model every five minutes
and this makes a big difference for
click-through rate and and the relevance
of the recommendations that they're
making and and dance is not the only
company where online learning is
important and being able to quickly have
a short turnaround time between data
coming in and recommendations going out
this is relevance at a number of
different companies as well so this is
one this is one example of an
application that crosses that integrates
many different computational patterns
and is difficult to do with just one
system like a distributed training
system or a stream processing system
okay so now I'm going to tell you a bit
about how Ray works how you can build
applications like this what the API
looks like so at its core ray is a
library for doing parallel and
distributed Python here are two very to
irregular Python functions one for
reading an array from a file and one for
adding two arrays together this is a toy
example to illustrate the API so the
generality of Ray comes from the fact
that we take two core concepts in
regular programming so functions and
classes and provide a way to translate
those two concepts into the distributed
setting as tasks and actors and I'll
explain that now
so if we want to execute these functions
in the distributed setting we can add
this ray dot remote decorator and now
when I when I invoke one of these
functions so I call read array dot
remote what that does is it immediately
returns a future so essentially a
pointer to the eventual output of the
computation and it starts the task
executing somewhere in the cluster so
here there's some worker process
somewhere in the cluster that is
executing this read array function now
because it immediately returns the
future when I call read array dot remote
I can call a second one before the first
one has finished so now I have two of
these tasks executing in parallel so
this is how future is enable parallelism
so now if these two lines of code in the
bottom have run already but and that
they've started these two tasks that are
running in parallel but haven't finished
yet and now I can start a third task
which depends on the outputs of the
first two tasks so here this takes in as
this third task won't actually start
executing until the first two have
finished and the outputs of the first
two have been transferred as inputs to
this to the last task and now if we
actually want to retrieve the output of
the computation we can call Rea dot yet
at the bottom to actually fetch the
outputs so this is if you're familiar
with the concept of futures or
composable futures that's exactly what's
going on here it's a very powerful
concept and you can implement a lot of
different workloads and applications
this way
so one thing this doesn't do however is
it doesn't let you share mutable states
between multiple different tasks and
that's very important for a lot of
machine learning applications or
reinforcement learning applications this
state that needs to get shared between
tasks occurs in the form of neural net
weights or simulator states and things
like that
and when you're programming on in when
you're writing python scripts on your
laptop the natural way to encapsulate
state is by using Python classes and so
we provide an actor
abstraction we take regular classes and
add this ray dot remote decorator and
that lets us essentially take a Python
class and spin it up as an actor or a
service somewhere in the cluster so now
when I create an instance of this class
that starts a new process which has a
copy of this object and now method
invocations on this object turn into
tasks that are executed remotely on the
newly created process and this is of
course a toy example where I have a
counter object which has a value that
can get incremented by one every time
you call the method so this is the this
is the bulk of the API they're
essentially two concepts we take
functions and classes and translate
those into the distributed setting and
that's important for generality if you
think about distributed systems like
spark the core abstraction in spark is
essentially a data frame or a data set
and you can transform the data set and
perform a number of operations that way
and that's great but if you're writing
Python programs with functions and
classes and then you want to run it in
the distributed setting with spark that
means you're sort of reacting your
codebase around the concept of a data
set here if you're starting with
functions and classes you can just take
those concepts and sort of naturally
translate them into the distributed
setting so that's why model like
adapting a code base to execute in the
distributed setting on a cluster using
ray typically takes fairly few lines of
code okay so this was a toy example let
me try to give a slightly more realistic
example with distributed training with a
parameter server so a parameter server
is a technique used for data parallel
and model parallel distributed training
and parameter servers are typically
implemented as their own standalone
distributed systems so but as a as an
abstraction a parameter server is
essentially you can think of it almost
like a key value store it holds the
weights of a neural net or the weights
of some machine learning model and it
exposes methods for getting the latest
parameters and updating those parameters
and that's what we've
adhere as a Python class with two
methods one for getting the parameters
and one for updating the parameters and
now by adding this decorator on top we
can start up this parameter server
object as a service or as an actor in
your cluster okay so how do we do
training well we can define a Python
function which is our worker that's
going to be computing gradients it takes
in a handle to the parameter server so
this PS argument that's being passed
into the worker is essentially a handle
that can be used to invoke methods on
the other on the parameter server
process this Pratt this worker is going
to loop around it's going to do three
things it first gets the latest
parameters from the parameter server
then it's going to compute some gradient
update using those parameters and this
is where I would also use tensorflow or
pi torch it would also use data that it
has locally to compute that gradient
update and then it's gonna send the
gradient update back to the parameter
server and the parameter server will
update its parameters so there's nothing
parallel happening here yet this is you
have two processes that are
communicating with each other
to do training but say we want to start
doing data parallel training and
computing multiple gradients in parallel
well the natural way to do that is to
start multiple copies of this worker
process so now we have three different
workers running in parallel that's are
all getting updates from the parameter
server and sending their updates back to
the parameter server okay so now we have
data parallel training happening
but what if our parameter server becomes
the bottleneck say that there's too much
communication happening to the parameter
server and it's it's either network
bound or compute bound or something like
that
well then we can do start to do model
parallel training so we can take our one
form of model parallel training we can
take our parameters of our machine
learning model and shard them or split
them across multiple different parameter
server processes and now all the workers
are going to be communicating with all
of the different parameters servers so
you can start to see how so the code
that I wrote here is not the complete
example but it's a large fraction of it
and when you think about how a parameter
server is normally some
that's implemented with its own big C++
code base it's something that it's it's
a standalone distributed system
something you might interact with kind
of like a database and to be able to
take that and implement it instead as a
you know 10 or 15 lines of Python code
is extremely powerful and this also
makes it much more configurable if you
want to do things differently say you
want to change the parameter server
update rule well it's it's a line of
Python that we wrote over there and you
can change it if you want to switch from
synchronous to asynchronous training or
vice-versa
or if you want to handle stragglers
differently or if you want to have
backup workers to avoid stragglers these
are all things you can add into your
application with a few extra lines of
code whereas sometimes making that kind
of change to an existing parameter
server is a very invasive change so
hopefully this gives you a taste of how
what it might mean to take a distributed
system and reimagine it as a library on
top of a higher-level general-purpose
framework okay so now I'll say a bit
about the rate architecture the backend
and what kind of architecture supports
this API so here's a depiction of a
three node cluster so three separate
physical machines each machine is going
to have a number of different worker or
driver processes on it so the driver is
essentially the the script that you're
running your application that's kicking
off that's initiating the computation
that's running it and the workers are
going to be started by Ray to execute
the different tasks so each machine has
a shared memory object store on it so
this is essentially a key value store
that uses shared memory to efficiently
allow workers to all access the same
data without creating their own copies
and without doing expensive D
serialization so this is a performance
optimization and it's a super important
performance optimization because large
numerical data comes up all over the
place in machine learning and
reinforcement learning applications and
you need to be able to that could be
like large images video
neural net weights data sets things like
that and it's important to be able to
share these things efficiently without
having each process have to create its
own copy and and serialize and
deserialize these things all the time so
this is based on the Apache arrow
project which is a large data layout for
big data that's language agnostic and
that's something that we're building on
top of so objects are streamed between
different between different machines you
through an object manager and a
scheduler on each machine is responsible
for assigning different tasks to
different workers and of giving
different tasks to different machines we
take a distributed scheduling approach
where each machine has its own scheduler
because centralized schedulers can can
be a bottleneck with a finite throughput
so a lot of systems use centralized
schedulers and these schedulers
typically have a throughput of like five
to ten thousand tasks per second okay so
lastly there is a sharded database that
this global control store which is
responsible for storing critical system
information for recovering from failures
so if a machine dies and we lose some
important data then we'll recreate that
data by rerunning the tasks that are
needed that created that data and the
specifications of those tasks are stored
in the global control store so that's
there are two forms of fault tolerance
we provide that's one of them and others
in the form of check pointing actor
state and reloading from checkpoint s'
okay so that's that's what the
architecture looks like so how does the
API map onto this architecture if you go
back to our initial example where we
have these three tasks that we started
the first two executing in parallel and
the third depends on the first two what
happens when we actually run that code
well this computation graph is depicted
in the bottom corner when we actually
run that code these three tasks are
submitted to the scheduler on the
machine that the tasks are submitted on
and the scheduler will now start to
assign one task
to one worker and maybe it will take you
the second task give it to a different
machine and that machine will assign it
to a different worker so now that's one
way that these tasks can be scheduled so
now these two tasks will start executing
in parallel and when they and when they
finish
they'll when they finish running they'll
store their outputs in the shared memory
object store okay so now that we've
finished running the first two tasks
we're ready to start executing the third
task so the third task will be given to
some worker now the worker this this
third task requires the outputs of the
first two tasks as inputs so the first
output is already on the right machine
so that'll be given to the worker but
the second output needs to be
transferred over to the first machine
and then given to the worker and now
that the worker has all of its inputs it
can start executing the task and that
task will run and then eventually it'll
finish and its output will be stored
back into the object store and so now
that that's done the last thing that
will happen and this has actually done
asynchronously is that the
specifications of these tasks are stored
in this persistent global control store
to be able to recover in the event of
failures so that's a little bit about
how the applications actually get
executed by this back-end I should
mention that the backend itself is
written in C++ the API is exposed
primarily through Python we also have
support for Java and some support for
cross language function invocation so
I'm invoking Python functions from Java
and things like that but Python is our
primary use case okay so now I'm going
to switch gears a little bit and start
to tell you about the different
libraries and ecosystems that are being
built on top of ray so I've described
the core array system and its API but to
really support the machine learning
ecosystem well we need to provide higher
higher-level tools and easy to use
libraries for the common computational
patterns so hyper parameter tuning and
I'll say what hyper parameter tuning is
in a second
hyper parameter we have a so Ray tune is
a hyper parameter search framework
that's built on top of Ray it's built
using the core rate task and actor
abstractions there are a number of other
different distributed hyper parameter
search libraries out there they're
typically built as standalone
distributed systems so the fact that
we're able to take something like this
and implement it on top of Ray is a
testament to the generality of the
underlying framework so what actually is
a hyper parameter here's a depiction of
a convolutional neural net this is
something for taking in images and
outputting labels and convolutional
neural nets are super powerful they're
responsible for a lot of the advances in
computer vision recently and we all know
how long it can take to train these
models but one thing that's less
well-known is how how much time is spent
getting these architectures right and
designing the architecture and to be to
be just right so there are a number of
different choices that go into designing
this neural net architecture you can see
there are all these different boxes they
have different sizes that need to be
chosen we have to choose the number of
hidden units in each layer the sizes of
the the window sizes for these
convolutions the down the rate at which
we down sample the number of pixels we
skip in our convolutions the
optimization algorithms also have hyper
parameters things like the learning
rates or the momentum that we're using
so all of these different choices have
big implications for the performance of
the overall model and the process and
these are what we refer to as hyper
parameters so the loss the thing we
actually care about the objective is
typically it's a differentiable or
continuous function of the the neural
net parameters but it's typically a non
differentiable and non continuous
function of the hyper parameters and so
Hyper parameter tuning is important but
it's time-consuming and and twisting
tuning all of these knobs can make a big
difference for the overall and accuracy
so why do here's an example from
reinforce of reinforcement learning
benchmark in which we are learning to
control the motion of a cheetah of a
simulated cheetah and the only thing
that differs here the learning algorithm
is the same the only thing that differs
here is the number of hidden units and
then in the neural net architecture and
as you can see adding more and more
hidden units actually causes a big
decline in the overall performance and
this is an example of the choice of
hyper parameter making a big difference
for the end accuracy so how do you get
around this problem of setting the hyper
parameters well one way is to just
search over the different possibilities
and so there are a number of reasons to
use a framework for hyper parameter
tuning one is that you want the best
model and that means you're either and
you don't want to sit there in front of
your screen
repeatedly running experiments waiting
for the results tweaking the inputs a
little bit and then relaunching more
experiments you want this process to be
automated the second reason is cost both
in terms of physical resources like GPUs
and also in terms of time so you want
the best model as quickly as possible
and so these involve decisions like
killing experiments that are running
that are performing poorly killing them
stopping them early or devoting more
resources to the ones that are
performing well these are the kinds of
decisions that can be made by a hybrid
parameter search framework that can
speed up training a lot but that you
don't want to have to re-implement for
every new model that you're doing so
those are some things you can do with
with tune and and one of the benefits of
using a framework for hyper parameter
tuning so there are a lot of things
hyper parameter searches a is a general
concept that isn't specific to deep
learning but deep learning is one of the
dominant use cases one of the settings
where it's the most important price
precisely because of how expensive
training can be in this setting
so to support deep learning well there
are several things we have to do one is
to have you know just absolutely perfect
support for GPUs and custom resources
like that
another is scalability and being able to
run the same code on your laptop or on a
large cluster and those first two points
are things that we inherit automatically
from you building on top of Rea the
third thing is you have to be able to it
has to be extensible and that's in order
to take advantage of state-of-the-art
algorithms that are being invented all
of the time and the last thing is it has
to work with absolutely every single
deep learning framework so things like
pi torch tensorflow etc and as well as
non deep learning frameworks like
scikit-learn and general-purpose Python
code arbitrary Python code so these are
all things that are important for
features of a hyper parameter tuning
framework so like I've mentioned earlier
hyper parameter tuning frameworks often
require you to re-architect your code
base around around the framework and
that's that explicitly something we're
trying to avoid with tune so in my
experience adapting a code base to do
hyper parameter search using tune
typically takes around ten lines of code
and we have two different API so one is
a function based API for getting up and
running quickly and another is a class
based API which supports fancier
features like check pointing and saving
and restoring and this is used for for
stopping certain trials early and
restarting them later on so another
advantage of tune are the abstractions
that we provide so you can see there are
blue and orange boxes so the blue boxes
are search algorithms things for
suggesting the next set of hyper
parameters to try this is what we
typically think of as hyper parameter
search so things like Bayesian
optimization grid search random search
these are algorithms for suggesting the
next set of hyper parameters to try then
we have these orange boxes which are
trial schedulers we
essentially specify how the execution is
performed so orthogonal to what trials
what hyper parameters we should try this
specifies the details of which trials we
should devote more resources to which
ones we should stop early and things
like that and you can take any blue box
in any orange box and combine them
together with with two lines of code
using tuned and so these are some of the
abstractions that a typical a typical
hyper parameter search framework will
actually just choose one box either blue
or orange and then a build a framework
around that and that can make it very
difficult to or require a lot of extra
effort to integrate with other different
choices so this is the choice getting
the abstractions right here is super
important and again being able to
combine these different abstractions or
these different choices in the right way
can make a big difference for the
overall performance so now I'm going to
talk about our ellipse so our l-live is
a reinforcement learning library that's
built on top of Ray here is where it
sits in the overall stack so it sits
alongside tuned and our other libraries
that we're building it's built on top of
the core array tasks and actor
abstractions now what is reinforcement
learning so reinforcement learning is a
framework that can be used to describe
many different problems so if you think
of supervised learning as the setting in
which you take in a data point X and you
output a label Y reinforcement learning
is not about making a single prediction
but rather about taking a sequence of
actions in a dynamically changing
environments and then getting feedback
about how well you how well how could
those actions were in order to adapt the
policy for taking actions but the
feedback may be very delayed so as you
can imagine this setup can be used to
describe many different kinds of
problems like dialogue health
applications things in robotics board
games and autonomous driving and the
fact that you can one thing that's worth
pointing out though is the fact that
you can describe many different problems
using this language doesn't mean that an
off-the-shelf reinforcement learning
algorithm is going to solve these out of
the box a lot of care or a lot currently
depends on the actual formulation of the
problem how you've defined the reward
function how you define the objective
and things like that so there are two
key components to a reinforcement
learning application one is the
environment this essentially defines the
problem set up so that could be a
robotic environment that could be a
board game things like that and then
there's the agent which is the thing
that you're trying to control so you're
trying to define a policy learn a policy
which controls the behavior of this
agent and what actions it takes in the
environment so these two components
operate in a tight loop with each other
where the agent continually takes new
actions and those actions have an effect
on the environment they change the state
of the environments the agent then
observes the new state of the
environment and possibly a reward or or
a penalty and that will and then the
agent will take a new action and the
process continues so there to give an
example of how you can frame go in this
example go is a board game the
environment is essentially the state of
the board game and locations of all the
pieces on it and the agent is the
function that you're using to decide
where to place the next piece and so
this is a fully observed environment and
unlike supervised learning in which you
place a you might place a piece and then
so in supervised if we were to treat
this as a supervised learning problem we
would want to have a data set of a bunch
of different board States and then the
correct move or the best move to play in
that in that location and from that
board state and if we're doing that not
only would we need to somehow get this
data set then we would train the model
to predict the best move given a board
state and then we would see whether it
was right or wrong and we would update
the model based on that with
reinforcement learning
you are playing you're making the move
and you're taking the sequence of
actions and then you don't necessarily
know if you won or lost the game until
the very end so at the very end you get
one bit of feedback whether you won or
lost
and then that single bit of feedback is
used to update the entire the entire the
policy for deciding what actions to play
nevertheless so it sounds like a small
amount of feedback but this is something
that has been successfully where
reinforcement learning has been
successfully applied to to play go very
well another application is in
controlling the tilt of antennas so by
focusing antennas in the right locations
and the right angles you can provide
better service and better throughput for
the cell network and this is something
that is difficult to do currently at the
and is only adapted at the timescale of
days but preliminary results suggest
that by using reinforcement learning we
can control the placement of antennas
better in order to improve throughput
for the cell network okay so now I'm
going to say a little bit about the
design of a library for reinforcement
learning so at the bottom we're building
on top of raised core abstractions for
of tasks and actors to provide building
blocks that can be used to implement
distributed reinforcement learning
algorithms on top of that you were using
these building blocks to provide a
collection of state-of-the-art reference
implementations of a number of different
reinforcement learning algorithms and
then on top of that we're exposing these
algorithms in easy-to-use ways to a
number of different types of
applications and that includes things
like multi agent reinforcement learning
problems as well as policy serving and
things like that so these are some of
the different levels of abstractions
multi agent reinforcement learning is
actually a really a growing area and
this you can think about regular
reinforcement learning is learning to
control one agent but there may be many
settings in which you actually want to
well a number of agents together and one
example of this is modeling traffic so
if you think about every there could
there's a Paula there could be a policy
controlling every single traffic light
deciding when it should be green or when
it should be red every car might be its
own agent as well and in this setting
the interesting thing is not necessarily
just controlling one of these agents
individually but how you can control
them all together in order to optimize
traffic so here's a quick overview of a
number of the different algorithm
reinforcement learning algorithms that
we've implemented in RL lib and you'll
notice that a bunch of these are
actually community contributions all of
this is open source and and so
contributing a new algorithm is as
simple as opening a pull request and
because these are all building on top of
building blocks for distributed
reinforcement learning this is doesn't
mean reimplemented the full algorithm
from scratch there's a lot of code reuse
here this is integrated with Ray tune so
hyper parameter search is super
important for for reinforcement learning
but they can be difficult to compose
together when you want to do distributed
reinforcement learning inside of a
distributed hyper parameter search and
you know if your reinforcement learning
and hyper parameter search are two
separate distributed systems it can be
hard to nest them inside of each other
or compose them in that way but when
they're built on top of a single
general-purpose system then it's easier
to do that the last thing I want to say
about reinforcement learning for RL lib
is that it is ships with part of sage
makers so if you use Amazon sage maker
you can use RL lib as part of that one
last library I want to talk about is
modem which is a library for speeding up
pandas if you use pandas for data
science this involves changing a single
line of code so pant so data processing
this is a live room where building again
on top of the core array abstractions of
tasks and actors again systems like
spark or Hadoop for distributed data
processing
typically built as standalone
distributed systems so the fact that
we're able to build this on top of Ray
is again testament to the generality of
Ray they're typically what's the problem
here there are different tools for doing
data science and data processing some of
them like pandas work well with small
data on your laptop but pandas isn't
going to run on a cluster and similarly
their tools like spark which are great
for huge data but aren't going to speed
things up on I'll sing on your laptop
beyond pandas and some Odin bridges that
gap if you have a line like import
pandas as PD somewhere in your code base
you can replace that with import mode in
pandas as PD and that's the only change
you would need to make so I will and
here's an example of just a quick
benchmark for reading a large CSV file
as a function of the size of the CSV
file on a single large machine so as you
can imagine the larger the file the
longer pandas takes and if you're using
mode and instead it's able to leverage
multiple cores to read those files much
more quickly and this is a difference
between you know 10 15 seconds and a 7
or so minutes so I'll conclude by saying
that again ray is open source it's
intended to be a general-purpose
distributed system and we've seen that
we can take things that are
traditionally standalone distributed
systems like reinforcement learning
hyper parameter tuning distributed data
processing and implement all of those as
libraries on top of ray and what that
allows is that applications that need to
combine these different things can do so
on top of ray we can implement and
support these cross-cutting applications
that touch many different computational
patterns so it's all on github I'd
encourage you to check it out
oh thanks a lot
really good talk thanks for sharing it
so would you advocate raise use even in
single terminal settings just because
you can use Python across multiple
course so yes if you have more than one
or two if you have a certainly for large
machines if you have more than four
cores than absolutely so a typical way
that we'll do development is we'll start
we'll start just prototyping things in
Python single threaded then I'll
parallel parallel why's that across
multiple cores on my laptop or on a
single machine using Ray and that's
typically just adding a few annotations
and then when I rot when that's too big
for my laptop or for a single machine
then I'll take that and run the same
code on a on a cluster and so there's
sort of a seamless transition from like
single threaded to parallel on a single
machine to the cluster setting and
instead of having to sort of rewrite the
code at that stage and the single
machine case is especially important
because there are many large machines
you can start up a big you know instance
on ec2 that has like a hundred cores or
something like that so yeah that's a
very important use case all right any
other question thanks for the talk
question about out just future support
for the platform do you guys plan on you
know keep developing further and
supporting in the future and yes what
that looks like
yes so yeah the plan is to keep working
on it and to make it really good and to
grow the community around it to grow to
grow the community of developers and
users and and these things beeston
a lot of the development is at Berkeley
but there are actually a number of
contributions from different companies
using Ray as well and the and again the
plan is to yeah to have more development
from that's an important metric we look
at just external contributors
is the plan to take this to like an
Apache or a Linux Foundation or is it
we're open to it if there's a compelling
reason but so far it hasn't seemed to be
necessary
[Music]